bom dia muito obrigada pela
receptividade é um prazer estar aqui
representando também o campus guarulhos
eu sou servidora da casa
atualmente atua na direção de
infraestrutura contribuindo com o
andamento do desenvolvimento do campus e
desde 2015 eu venho desenvolvendo um
projeto de extensão do campus
o projeto de extensão se chama
construindo cidadãos que é um projeto em
parceria com o clube de desbravadores
para crianças de 10 a 15 anos ea gente
fez essa parceria com o clube justamente
para atender os pessoal da do abrigo que
é que próximo
e aí a gente vem trabalhando com eles e
vendo quão importante é trabalhar com
crianças que em muitos momentos foram
deixados para trás ea gente vem tentando
reanimar reinserir e trazê la lys para
estar em sociedade
eu conto com dois bolsistas a lista o
nome delas como eu já havia falado a
gente trabalha é com crianças de 10 a 15
anos ea gente está em média com um
público de 52 juvenis em parceria com o
clube
bem o objetivo principal do projeto é a
gente fazer o desenvolvimento físico
mental e social da criança né do a
juvenil e do adolescente
a nossa preocupação é que ele faça
várias atividades nessa fase da
puberdade é uma fase tão difícil que é a
fase das escolhas que é a fase em que
eles são imersos num mundo do adulto
ainda sendo criança e eles ainda estão
em desenvolvimento ea gente procura
trazer várias atividades que vão ser
útil nesse desenvolvimento dele de forma
harmônica e aí a gente vai trabalhando
de acordo com a idade com atividades
para desenvolver esse juvenil esse
adolescente
nessa difícil fase da puberdade bem a
metodologia que a gente utiliza pode
voltar favor aqui
antes a gente fala da metodologia vou
falar dos objetivos específicos nem quer
desenvolver consciência sócio-ambiental
fortalecer a criatividade e incentivar o
combate ao uso de drogas orientar sobre
o estilo de vida saudável construir
habilidades com disciplina desenvolver
amor à pátria e preparados para o
trabalho em equipe e aconselhar também
para que sempre sejam úteis à comunidade
e também fazer uma criação de um
espírito altruísta e além de tudo
oportunizar o campus tombos guarulhos
pra que eles têm um desejo de estudar
aqui muito em breve e formar amigos num
grupo saudável e está com pessoas
fazendo atividades saudáveis
a metodologia que a gente usa cada faixa
etária a gente trabalha com um cartão
com atividades e esse cartão desenvolve
a criança na parte física eles têm que
fazer atividades físicas
e aí também atividades que desenvolve a
parte mental ele faz especialidade por
exemplo de arte de acampar e aí ele vai
aprender várias coisas sobre a arte de
cantar aprendi sobre fogueira aprendi
sobre como é fazer uma fogueira na mata
como é mesmo durante a chuva faz
conseguir fazer uma fogueira e aí eles
são investidos na especialidade de arte
de acampar
esse é um dos itens de um cartão que é
feito durante um ano é uma atividade que
é realizado durante um ano de acordo com
a faixa etária e aí como é que a gente
vai desenvolvendo a as três áreas deles
fazendo os requisitos desses cartões por
idade por exemplo quem é do cartão de
amigos de 10 anos a criança tem ainda
com a necessidade de um espírito de
liderança forte desse vôo
um grupo de amigos que o acolheu então o
cartão desenvolve a amizade por isso o
nome do cartão chama-se amigo e aí ele
faz várias atividades que faz com que
ele se integra ao grupo que faça com que
ele torna se amigo de todas as crianças
e se sinta acolhido
já uma criança de 13 anos a gente já vai
trabalhar com ela a pressão de grupo
como não sofrer pressão na hora que ele
for convidado a usar drogas
e aí a gente vai trabalhando várias
coisas peculiar a idade da criança né a
é bem amplo o currículo de atividades
que a gente faz com eles e age assim os
encontros eles se consiste em quatro
atividades
quando eles chegam a gente faz 30
minutos de ordem unida que é justamente
para trabalhar
a disciplina coordenação motora e o
senso de hierarquia e eles fazem ordem
unida e também trabalhar um senso de
unidade porque eles são dividido em
unidades entre seis a oito crianças para
cada adulto e esse adulto que é chamado
de conselheiro é responsável por esse
grupo é o adulto que vai ajudar esse
grupo a se desenvolver
e aí depois que termina a ordem unida
a gente parte para essa fase do de um
cantinho que a gente chama de cantinho
da unidade que é o momento que o
conselheiro vai conversar com o aluno
perguntar ele como é que ele está o
andamento dele na escola como é que está
o andamento dele com o relacionamento
com os pais como está o andamento dele
na sua vida durante aquela semana e aí o
terceiro momento é o momento das
instruções que é são esses aqui dos
cartões que é o momento de
desenvolvimento mental em que a gente
trabalha várias atividades de
crescimento intelecto da criança e no
final a gente faz uma recriação onde a
gente faz várias dinâmicas de grupo onde
a gente está trabalhando com eles de
forma que eles se desenvolvam a cada dia
para estarem unidos em grupo bem onu em
geral aqui a gente tem mais os rios
estados das especialidades que lhes
foram investidos das classes que eles
foram investidos mas eu gostaria de
falar muito além desses resultados das
investiduras das condecorações que eles
receberam
eu gostaria de falar desenvolvimento
deles enquanto pessoas né
quando eles chegaram no projeto as
crianças do abrigo eles não queriam
participar da ordem unida não queriam e
ficavam receosos e no seu canto
retraídos porque pra eles é muito
difícil criar vínculos porque em muitos
momentos os vínculos foram quebrados
então eles em uma já ficam de pé atrás e
aí com o tempo a gente foi deixando
assim não querem participar da ordem
unida então tá bom e aí eles ficavam
aguardando até eles sentirem desejo de
participar de alguma atividade bem no
começo lá em 2015
e aí com o tempo ele já começaram aí a
gente fez um encontro de ordem unida e
várias pessoas apresentaram ordem unida
e eles a partir do próximo encontro já
queriam ficar também esperto senhor de
unido e aí já começaram a participar da
ordem unida e aos poucos néon 11 torno
de dois meses eles já estavam totalmente
integrados ao grupo já gostavam de todas
as atividades já queriam participar de
todas as atividades e logo em seguida
uns dois meses depois a gente já levou
eles primeiro acampamento aqui a
investidura onde eles receberam as
medalhas eo mais e é esse que é uma das
atividades sociais a gente fez uma
distribuição de brinquedos porque para
eles que sempre só recebem é importante
participar da doação e saber que eles
são importantes na comunidade que poucas
ações que eles fazem faz a diferença
para o outro e aqui um acampamento que a
gente realizou lá no if de bom jesus
onde estiveram várias atividades
aprendendo como é
a dinâmica do campo bom jesus quais são
as atividades agrícolas class são
desenvolvidas aí eles tiveram
oportunidade de plantar árvores de
colher ovos né e aí já é a parte da
fogueira noite do fogo do concelho
naquela foto eles estão aprendendo como
o alimento é processado no campus de bom
jesus e aqui uma caminhada que a gente
fez ao morro do itaó khan e aqui é a
parte que a gente faz sempre de
incentivo à leitura eles lêem dois
livros por ano e aqui a parte que a
gente está conversando sobre o capítulo
do livro que eles estavam lendo naquela
semana
a participação deles no desfile de 7 de
setembro do ano passado
e aqui é um evento onde reúne
desbravadores de toda todos os três
estados minas espírito santo e rio de
janeiro ea gente teve oportunidade de
oportunidade de levar todo o grupo para
participar junto desse evento e que foi
olimpíadas que ocorrerão em campos e
eles foram vitoriosos em várias das
modalidades receberão as medalhas
a gente tem poucas fotos porque a gente
não pode mostrar o rosto das crianças
mas os que podem aparecer que não são
crianças do abrigo estão aí né mostrando
a felicidade que é participar de
atividades saudáveis com crianças da sua
idade e quanto isso desenvolve ea gente
pôde perceber que crianças que por
exemplo tinham muita dificuldade de
relacionamento de socialização
a gente tem um caso de uma assistida que
tinham dificuldade no processo de adoção
e após a participação do projeto ela
hoje já não participa do projeto pois
foi adotada no final do ano passado ela
irmãozinho dela porque ela passou a lei
passou a se socializar passou a
conversar melhor e ficou menos é
preocupada de como o outro irá receber
e esse processo de socialização
proporcionou que ela pudesse junto com
seu irmão é passar pela adoção no ano
passado
então esses resultados são muito
melhores do que os resultados do dia a
dia que é os resultados das investiduras
que eles recebem das condecorações que
eles recebem
mas o resultado da inclusão social e da
percepção de que eles são úteis à
sociedade e podem trabalhar para a
sociedade e que eles são inseridos nela
bem aí é um pouco do que eu já falei de
como que que é importante na vida deles
participarem de um projeto onde eles
estão fazendo coisas saudáveis com
pessoas da idade deles e as referências
ou muito obrigada pela participação
[Aplausos]